Hello and welcome to this video. We will be moving on with the exercise at this point
and what we're going to be doing is we are going to be connecting up the door so that it can
accept inputs from the keyboard and we are going to be making the door open and close
on command. Okay so I've cleared away any of the code that I was experimenting with
and now I'm going to go about making the functionality for our door.
Right well I have a number of settings here. What I'm going to start with is my collision box. Now
what I want to do with my collision box is I'm going to use this to detect when the player is
close or far away from the door and this means we'll be able to know if the player would
be able to interact with it or not. So I'm going to right hand click on the component
in the components list and you'll see the second one down we have add event. Now these are a
number of events which are already connected to actor component working and we want two of
these. So the first one we want is the on component begin overlap. It's going to create
this one and I'm going to right-hand click and I'm going to grab on component end overlap. So
what this will do is when any actor overlaps with our ox component here this event would
be triggered as long as the collisions are set up correctly. So what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to test this out. So I'm going to drag off of the on component in begin overlap. I'm going
to search for print string and I will then duplicate that down to here. On the first one
I'm going to type overlap and on the second one I'm going to type end overlap. So what this
will do is it will print this message into the top left hand corner of the screen. So let's test
this out and jump back to my level. Now this is the player start so this is where we'll start
off correctly in front of the door. So when I push start I can see the door and as I walk
forward overlap appears in the top left hand corner and as I move away end overlap. So that is
working. Press escape. Come back out. I'm going to delete both of these because we don't need them.
Now what I want to do is I want to be able to push a key when I am close to these doors. So
in order for the actor to be able to register a key press it needs to have a Mabel input
set on this. And we talked about this before. The player controller is the class which is set up
in order to listen for inputs. Now this actor itself doesn't have the functionality
but what it can do is it can piggyback off of the standard player controller. And we can do this
in this way. So if I right-hand click and search for player controller you'll see that there is
a option for get player controller. You'll see that here under game and that's going to bring
up the player controller for player index zero. Now we only have one player so that's fine.
But what we're going to want to do is drag off and go enable input. Place that up here.
I'm going to drag down and I'm going to go disable input. And I'll plug these into the appropriate
boxes. Now there's one more thing we need to do otherwise this won't work. If we look at the
enable input and disable input you can see that there are two input pins. The top one is the
target. So that is the actor on which we want to enable the input on. And the second one is
the player controller. So this is the player controller which we would be listening to the
input for. Now we have this linked to the wrong one. I'm going to hold down the control button
to get up the little hand and drag this player controller down so that it plugs into the player
controller. And the target will default to self which is exactly what we want. So this
now enables and disables the player input. Now that we have access to the player controller
we can now put functionality in here which would work with the key presses. So what I'm
going to do is I'm going to come down beneath these two and I'm going to type in key and then
z. You'll see this will bring up a couple of options. And I'm going to select the bottom
one here from the keyboard z. And you can see that this is another red event which is just
for the input key z. Now I don't actually want this to be z and I want this to be e.
So with this selected rather than search for the e I find it a lot quicker to search for z because
it's the only one in there. And then in the input keys I am going to look here and we have
a drop down box where I could select any input key. And I also have a sort of select key value
button here. All this will do is when I push it it's going to go orange and it will wait for
the next key press which is e and I'll swap it over to e. That's a nice quick way to bring up
the e key. Now to check that this is working correctly I'm going to do another print string
and I'm going to change it to pressed key and leave it as hello if you want. Push compile,
go back into the level, press play. Now if I press e nothing happens. However if I get close
to the door and press e you can see that the print string is now registered.
Okay further away you can see it's not registering. So that means that this is
functioning. The print key will only register when inputs are enabled. So what do we want to do
on the press e? I'm going to delete this now that we know that it's working. What we want to
do is we want to open and close the door. So in order to do that I'm going to drag off of the e
and I am going to search for something that's called a flip-flop. Now this is one of the
flow control nodes. It's a macro in itself. But how this will work is the first time that
you enter this node you'll go down the a execution pin. The second time you'll go through b.
Third time you'll go back to a and it will continue alternating between the two different
pins. Now this is useful for us because the first time that we push it we're going to
want to open the door and the second time we're going to want to close it.
Now the opening and closing we are going to use a timeline. So I am going to drag off and I'm
going to search for timeline. You can see at the bottom here we have the option for add timeline.
I'm just going to bring up this yellow node. I'm going to rename it open slash close
door. Now to start with we're going to play this. What I would like to do is connect the b
up to the reverse. So this is interesting. Let's have a look at closely to a timeline.
What a timeline will do, and we'll double click and go and set it up in a second,
but what it will do is when you play the timeline it will play a timeline over time
and return values based on a curve. When you reverse it at whatever point it is in the timeline
it will start going in the opposite direction. Now the update pin, anything which is connected
to the update pin, will run every frame of the game whilst the timeline is running.
So this is effectively tick. When the timeline is finished, from the end or beginning,
anything that is connected to the finish pin will then be executed. So bear in mind if you
have one that runs for one second and you're running at 60 frames per second, whatever is
connected to the update will run 60 times and then the finish will run once at the end of the
second. Okay let's set up this timeline. So if I double click on this we're going to get a
window that looks a bit like this. Now at the moment I'm not going to go into a lot of details
about what you do with the timeline, but let's have a look. We have the length here. Now this
is the amount of time in seconds that this will run for. Now five seconds is too long. So I'm going
to change this to one second. And next we need to add in a track. So you can see that we have
a plus track element here. If I was to push that button it's going to give me some options
of the kind of tracks that we could use. Now I'm going to select the float track.
And that's going to bring up a track that looks a little bit like this.
Now this is a standard curve and we are able to make points on the curve in order to
calculate how they function. So let's start off at the beginning and we're going to add a curve
out of point. As you can see we really want this to be at time zero and value zero. So you
can use these boxes here. And then I'm going to go to the end, right-hand click, add a float.
And this will be time one, and I want this to be value one. And that brings that up here.
Now I can hold down the right-hand mouse button and drag. Once I've got this in screen,
I am going to select both of these, then right-hand click on either of them.
I'm going to change the key interpolation to auto. So that's going to give me a little bit
of a curve in and a curve out. That'll allow the door movement to look a bit more realistic.
Okay so that gives us our value from zero to one. Now because this runs over one second,
when it first kicks off it will provide us the value of zero. And then at about halfway through
it will provide us the value of point five. And at the end it will provide us the value of one.
And it will give us various different numbers as the timeline progresses.
Okay so that's the timeline set up. Let's jump back into the event graph. And you'll
now see that we have a new track here, which is a float, which is a green pin.
I'm going to rename this to an open alpha. And I'll close that down again. So the open alpha
is the green pin. And this is going to return the value between zero and one.
Okay so what we want to do now is we want to rotate this door. So we know we've got the
door mesh in the components list here. I'm going to drag that out, place that into the screen.
And I'm going to drag off, I'm going to search for set relative rotation. And I'm going to plug
that into the update. So the relative rotation, and this is because we don't want to set the
world rotation, we want to set it relative to the actor, which is its parent, which is
the door frame at this point. So regardless of the direction that you place your door in,
it will rotate in a consistent manner. Now what I want to do is drag off the new rotation
and type in lerp rotator. Now if you haven't encountered a lerp before, what this will do
is based on a alpha, it will move between two values. So if the alpha is zero, it will return
a to the rotation. If the alpha is one, it will return b. If the alpha is 0.5, it will return
halfway between these two rotations. So what I'm going to do is I'm going to plug in the open
alpha into the alpha, and then I am happy with a being zero. Because if we look at the viewport,
the rotation is zero zero zero when the door is closed. What I want to do is figure out a
rotation for it being open. It's actually going to be zero zero 90. Okay, so I know that's
what I want it to be. So the second one, I'm going to make 90. Okay, so our full
code that we've got here looks like that. Let's test this out. So I'm going to hit compile.
I'm going to open up the level, and I'm going to push play. Now as I get closer, if I push
e, the door opens. If I push it again, it closes. And you'll see if I push it halfway through,
it moves from the position it originally was. So you can change your mind halfway
through the opening of the door. Okay. So that gives us our first animation.
If you were to look at this whilst it was running, I'm going to select our debug objects,
press play. You'll be able to see as I come in and press e, it triggers and opens the door.
As I press it again, it goes in the opposite direction. Fantastic. So that brings us to the
end of the basic creation of the door opening and closing. We will be building on that in
the next video. I'm going to be creating a function to change the light's colour.